[Music]
hello and welcome to sophie ridge on
sunday well i didn't expect to start my
first program back with this devastating
reality a war in europe civilians even
hospitals targeted millions of people
fleeing for their lives it's a reality
that seemed impossible even just a few
weeks ago and as we approach the third
week of the conflict and the bombardment
continues the focus here in the uk is
turning to how we can help the desperate
families who are leaving ukraine we'll
be analyzing the latest scheme from the
government and asking if it's enough
more than two million people have
already fled ukraine speed is everything
so on the program today we'll be
speaking to the man behind the homes for
ukraine scheme leveling up secretary
michael gove labour leader sakir stama
will also be here in the studio a man
who says he would welcome a ukrainian
refugee into his house
with reports of russian forces getting
ever closer to keeve we'll be getting a
first-hand account of the situation on
the ground from ukraine's deputy prime
minister
and we'll be talking to the ukrainian
member of parliament celestia vasilenko
who's picked up a gun herself plus we'll
be getting the russian perspective on
what president putin could do next
talking to leonard volkov the chief of
staff to putin's greatest critic alexis
navalny
[Music]
well more than 2.6 million people are
now thought to have fled ukraine and as
you would expect the nearest countries
have accepted the most refugees more
than a million have arrived in poland
alone in comparison the united kingdom
has accepted
1305 that's according to figures
published on thursday but is that about
to change with a new scheme offering 350
pounds a month to anyone who provides a
room for a ukrainian refugee well we'll
find out we're joined now by the
leveling up secretary michael gove to
explain more thank you very much for
being with us good morning i'm keen to
get to the latest scheme uh in just a
moment but first is there an update you
can give to us on what the latest
military situation is in ukraine well
the situation in ukraine is perilous um
it's uniquely challenging for the
ukrainian people and for their armed
forces um they've shown amazing bravery
and courage over the course of this
conflict but of course we know that
vladimir putin uh is prepared to
escalate there are several grisly
options that he has uh at his disposal
um and that's why it's so important that
we continue to provide all the support
that we can uh to uh president zielinski
and to his team what are those grizzly
options then well again we know that um
from what vladimir putin has done
elsewhere from what he's uh done in
syria and what he has done in chechnya
that he is capable of devastation on a
terrible terrible scale um and that is
why
we need to demonstrate solidarity with
the ukrainian people um and also that's
why the the military support the lethal
aid the united kingdom has been
providing threat and that other um nato
allies have been providing throughout is
so important but again we can't second
guess the decisions of the ukrainian
armed forces about chemical weapons and
the prime minister telling my colleague
beth rigby this week that that's
something that he fears well again i i i
don't want to um get into the weeds and
the detail of not really wheezing
details talking about the reality of a
chemical weapons attack well quite what
we know is that um uh putin's
calculation
uh that he would be able to
relatively quickly capture the the heart
of ukraine
that calculation has proven to be
unfounded we know that he is capable of
terrible terrible violence
but again
i am not a military expert and i would
not want
your viewers to think that i'm the right
person to get into a detailed discussion
of uh chemical or other warfare all i
can do is to is is to share with you
uh what um uh uh those of us in
government who are wrestling with this
no which is a
uh that putin's miscalculated b in the
past years shown a level of ruthlessness
beyond that which um any other leader on
earth is capable of at the moment and c
what happened in grossly what happened
in aleppo these are terrifying portents
um
obviously i understand you're not a
chemical weapons expert but if chemical
weapons are used that's a war crime how
do we respond is that the time when we
step up
uh our actions when it comes to the war
in ukraine well i think it's already
you're absolutely right it would be a
war crime um it was a war crime um uh in
syria it is the case that um already
vladimir putin has committed war crimes
already if he crosses the red line and
uses chemical weapons what is our
response well again uh our response uh
is something that will be agreed in
concert with our allies and it's not for
me at this stage and i can completely
understand your desire for for clarity
but it's not for me to spell out in
advance of um
nato and uh uh our allies being clear
about what they're saying what's the uk
government's position you won this
program as a representative by the uk
government what is the position on what
the uk response would be if putin uses
chemical weapons well it would be a
response specifically targeted to deal
with that escalation but i'm not going
to spell out myself what that response
is because it's for the prime minister
in concert with her allies to deal with
the situation which none of us would
want to see
i'm okay i'm understood um is there a
concern you know we're talking about an
escalation we'll be hearing from uh uh
mr volkov later and an ally of alexander
who says that he believes that putin is
crazy enough to use nuclear weapons is
that a real concern for the uk
government yes i think well i think
there are different um ways in which you
can describe how vladimir putin is
operating um i think he's operating
according to
uh a set of criteria totally detached
from um those which you or i would
consider to be reasonable or rational
but
by his own lights what he's doing is
pursuing a conflict which he believes he
has to win we have to make sure that he
loses there are people who are
um
even now calibrating what our response
should be to that the defense security
and intelligence experts in our own
country and elsewhere but yes i don't
think it's uh
helpful to think of putin as
mad
i think what we do need to uh think of
him as and we do need to recognize is
someone whose ruthlessness takes them
into a moral
sphere that the rest of us would find
almost impossible to conceive of and
that moral sphere could include the use
of nuclear weapons in your view well
again it's not for me to get into some
of the the detailed judgments about uh
uh the correct military response because
again uh not really detail is it
this is a huge you know very clear
question is that a real concern for the
uk government well
russia is a nuclear-armed power um its
military doctrine um uh it clearly has a
uh
a set of steps by which they can move to
that we're in perilous territory but
by definition
when you're talking about weapons of
such horrific potential and when you're
talking about strategy and diplomacy of
such delicacy then someone like me
shouldn't intrude into these
calculations this is a matter for heads
of government and for those with direct
military experience
and that's why i hope you'll excuse my
caution when we're dealing with such
momentous and potentially terrifying
escalation okay um
would you we're going to remove on to uh
refugees in the scheme you're announcing
uh now um do you have an update on the
number of refugees from ukraine that the
uk has accepted yes we've had um more
than 300 000 visas that have been issued
um and of course it's important to
recognize that from tuesday i'm talking
about the family scheme um uh from
tuesday it will be the case that uh uh
the majority people will no longer need
to apply for visas at visa application
centers will accept ukrainian passports
people will be able to come into this
country and as well as the number of
people who are coming in through the
family scheme which is rapidly expanded
as you mentioned right at the beginning
of the program there's a new homes for
ukraine scheme which also has no cap to
the number of people who can come here
so just to clarify 300 000 visas that's
up from 1 305 on thursday
3 000 more than three thousand views
more than three thousand right i was
going to say that is there quite a
very fast escalation otherwise um just
explain what your new
idea is to try and help refugees come to
the uk well we want to make sure that
every available bed
that
we have in this country that can be made
available every available home that can
be made available to those who are
fleeing persecution is mobilized um we
know that there are a large number of
people in this country generous-hearted
and in a position to provide homes and
businesses and to charities as well so
what we're doing is saying we the
government will act in solidarity and in
cooperation with you we will provide not
just a a payment um but we will also
make sure that people who come here have
the chance to work and get the support
from the nhs from education and from
other services that they need and so the
idea is that you register an interest
tomorrow monday are you going to be
registering an interest yourself well
i'm exploring what i can do yes and and
i think there'll be lots of people i i
understand the leader of the labor party
as well yeah are looking to see what
they can do and so you will be signing
up to try and offer a room well again
i'm going to make sure that i do
everything i can as an individual to
support um and again each individual
will have their own circumstances it is
the case that something like
one in 10 uk citizens which is an
amazing amount have said that they they
want to do something to help but we want
to make sure that people are in a
position to help because inevitably it's
a significant commitment and i recognize
that uh we need to operate in uh in
different ways and in different phases
to help people who are fleeing
persecution so are you offering a room
of i'm still not completely clear well
i'm in the process of seeking to see
what i can do yes and i again uh you
know as with so many things um i think
that there are individuals whose own
family circumstances mean that they can
or can't move as quickly as they'd like
um right let's talk numbers you say it's
uncapped but you must have done some
modeling what's your estimate for the
number of people who could come to the
uk through this scheme um tens of
thousands tens of thousands you think is
that enough if you look at the numbers
for example of ukrainian refugees poland
taking in 1.5
million france say they're expecting 50
to 100 000 in the coming weeks germany
over 80 000 by wednesday it still feels
you know tens of thousands it's
relatively no numbers if you look at the
level of the crisis yes and the number
of
children
elderly extremely vulnerable refugees is
that really enough well there are so
many things that we have to do um and
again
in a way in a face of crisis of this
magnitude um we have to make sure that
we do what we can when we can um and
that's why our approach is phased it's
also why it's um alongside the
humanitarian support that we're giving
so earlier this week leaders from four
of the countries closest to ukraine um
were meeting with the prime minister and
they were grateful to britain for
providing what's needed most now which
is humanitarian aid to those countries
on the front line who've taken such a as
you quite rightly point out huge influx
of individuals
once we do everything we can in order to
provide that humanitarian support
expertise uh boots on the ground money
uh alongside that we can then see how
many people we can take to the uk and
again many of the people who are there
um will want to at the moment stay
close to ukraine it is the case that for
family and other reasons there'll be
many people who will want to stay in
poland slovakia
or romania but of course there are many
others whom we can accommodate here who
can come here and to whom we wish to
give a warm welcome i want to talk a
little bit about the support that these
people will need when they come here
you're obviously having money that
you're giving to the sponsors of the
families um but it feels like a very
different profile of refugee to ones
that we've seen before you know there's
a lot of children yes a lot of elderly a
lot of people who will need access to
public services that you say the
government is willing to provide so does
that mean that you're looking at giving
more money to schools for example who
will be accepting ukrainian children yes
there'll be money available for local
authorities money available for much um
uh for each uh individual who comes will
be just over ten thousand pounds per
individual available to local
authorities then there's per per
individual ukrainian you're just willing
to fund up to ten thousand pounds in
service just over actually yes to to to
e each local government area um and then
there'll be additional payments for
those children who are off school age um
and who need to be accommodated within
the educational system
uh everyone will have access to uh full
nhs care including mental health the ten
thousand pounds that's to each local
authority area per individual per
individual right okay thank you and
that's um useful another thing that i
have some questions about is the fact
that you need to name a ukrainian in
order to accept them into your house
i mean
that's going to severely restrict
numbers isn't if you're a sky news
viewer for example you've got a spare
room you're desperate to do something to
help after you've seen the appalling
images from kiev and elsewhere
you don't know someone from ukraine do
you no but
you may do but
firstly the alternative to that would be
government attempting to match uh people
in ukraine to uh individuals here um and
uh that could be quite a slow
bureaucratic process um we know that
there are charities and we're working
with them that are helping to identify
people on the ground and helping to
identify people here to create that
matching process so rather than it being
simply government on its own we want to
make sure that uh the the web of
individual connections um and the the
good heartedness of those who are
supporting charities can help here so we
know that for example there will be
churches and faith groups that we know
that there will be jewish groups we know
that there will be
groups like stonewall and others that
will be doing everything they can to
identify individuals who can benefit and
individuals who want to help is there a
concern that people could effectively
match up with people on social media so
you see someone on instagram or on
twitter
and you could try and and perform links
that way yes that and part of the idea
yes and is there safeguarding concerns
over that you can effectively choose if
you like a vulnerable refugee that you
may have seen on instagram or twitter to
come into your personal home well one of
the reasons why we um uh are operating
the system in the way that we are is
precisely for that reason we absolutely
do need to make sure first of all that
the people um in ukraine
are who they they say they are so there
needs to be some security checks there
um there's
been understandable concern about this
scheme being exploited possibly by by
criminal elements um so that's the first
thing then the second thing is we do
need to make sure that people here are
who you know are are in a position
um to provide that support which is why
there will need to be security checks as
well to make sure that um those
i think it would only ever be a tiny
minority but still those who might be
intent on exploitation uh can be
prevented from uh abusing this system
and how quickly is all this going to
happen when could we expect to see the
first refugees entering the uk under
this people can register their interest
on um monday uh uh matching will be
taking place from friday um i would
expect that in a week's time we'll see
the first people coming here under the
scheme now
honestly has there been a bit of
disagreement in government over this
because if there's been reports of
number 10 blocking home office schemes
it feels as if there's been it's taken
quite a long time to get to this point
has there been any disagreement behind
the scenes about the best way to proceed
no what there's been is a very focused
determined effort to
get a scheme that uh that works and
meets the need of the hour so
um
you know people who are close politics
watchers will have seen and know that
i've been working very closely with the
home secretary throughout in order to
make sure that this scheme can work um
and it requires all of government so
uh it is the home office quite rightly
that is responsible for our security for
making sure the areas that we've just
mentioned that the people coming here
are the right people that the people
presenting are the right people you can
look at me in the eye and say you've got
full confidence the home office to
deliver the scheme yeah totally okay a
couple more questions before we end um
how hopeful are you that the talks
between russia and ukraine could end in
a resolution is there any compromised
deal that you can see been struck i pray
that we can have peace but it's
difficult to see what a compromise deal
would look like okay
and there's questions in the sunday
times uh about uh evgeny lebadek this is
the newspaper owner yes son of a former
kbg kgb
agent given a peerage by boris johnson
that the security uh services raised
questions about and it's also come out
that um back in 2013 the head of mi6
refused to meet him if this is a man and
he obviously denies any security but if
this is a man who the security services
have repeatedly raised concerns about is
the prime minister behaved a bit
foolishly to say the least here no i
don't think so um uh i've met um lord
lebedev as the prime minister has um at
no point did anyone ever say to me that
it would be inappropriate uh to meet him
and to um to talk to him and i think
none of those concerns are passed on
even though in 2013
the sunday times believes that they were
passed on to people at least around
boris johnson nobody has ever said to me
and um uh uh i've met mr mr lord
levidova as he knows in public um and
nobody has ever suggested to me that
that was wrong there's something else as
well i'd want to say so you're happy to
call him lord lebedev then yes
one of the other things i should say is
that um uh lord lavida has been clear
through the pages of the evening
standard the newspaper of which he is
proprietor that he wholeheartedly
disapproves of this conflict uh he's
been critical of vladimir putin's
actions i think one of the things that
vladimir putin would like us to do
is to uh have a an approach in the uk
where we said that everyone of russian
ancestry um was somehow
you know
this is no no
no but i
who the security services have
intervened over the period the head of
my sex refused to meet oh quite and it's
not just some
like normal russian person who lives on
your street
no uh but it's also the case that again
um i think it's um appropriate to
recognize that what um uh putin wants to
do is is to uh divide us in this way uh
again
the sunday times are reporting things
today
they're news to me um but of course i
take account fully of the integrity of
their reporting okay just finally and
the prime minister expected to travel to
saudi arabia next week for talking to
oil trying to move the uk away from
dependence on russia from russian energy
now of course this comes as saudi arabia
announces the execution of 81 men one of
the biggest mass executions for decades
are you comfortable with the uk relying
on oil from saudi arabia
well we have to rely on oil from a
number of countries um many of whose
human records human rights records we
wouldn't um um
in fact we don't approve of um every
time a uk government minister is in
saudi arabia we raise human rights
concerns alongside the other work that
we do i guess we arm the prize sell arms
to saudi arabia what's a little oil
well again saudi arabia is a security
partner of the united kingdom um i think
that there are human rights concerns
we're clear about those
but we also recognize that
at a time when the world is in a fragile
situation uh that uh diplomacy alongside
um uh clarity on human rights is
important okay thank you very much for
being on the program uh today michael
thank you not at all thank you
that was uh michael gove levelling up uh
secretary spelling out his uh ideas for
housing refugees well the labour leader
sekir stama says he would give a
ukrainian refugee a place in his home
the party had been broadly supportive of
the government that says action against
oligarchs must be faster and harder and
also says that boris johnson has
questions to answer over links to
russian money he joins us now in the
studio uh thank you very much for being
uh with us good morning uh good morning
so we've just heard michael go spelling
out his scheme to house uh ukrainian
refugees is that something you support
well look we've all seen the terrible
images from ukraine
and you know families fleeing for the
border fleeing for their lives and so
um you know i do think the uk has to
play its part
so far i think the home office and the
government's got it completely wrong the
scheme that they've put in place so far
has been too slow
too narrow
to mean
and you know we're where we were
essentially with afghanistan which is
only acting in the heat of the moment
now
do i think that you know where possible
people should play their part in britain
yes and i'm sure that many of the
british public will be incredibly
generous and welcoming
what would comfort me more frankly is if
i heard from michael gove that there are
plans in place for the support that's
actually going to be needed on arrival i
know that when
i was dealing with some of the afghan
families that arrived in my own
constituency during the course of the
summer
what i saw there is what i think we will
see in relation to ukraine
refugees which is traumatized families
desperately in need of support desperate
to know what's happening to their
relatives back in ukraine
just hit me out on this and come
straight back um needing the support in
terms of schooling work et
did say that and he said that there
would be 10 000 pounds per individual
made available to local authority areas
that that that is the support you're
talking about that's a good thing but if
if the government was announcing now
those plans in um hard edge form i would
have much more comfort in them well the
local authorities have been consulted
that the advice is being set up what i
saw in the summer was you know
saying that the money is going to go to
local authorities ten thousand pounds
he is but those plans just need to be in
place now so i'm not against the scheme
that he is proposing
i have to say the more you questioned
him the more i queried exactly how it's
going to work um but actually i'd have
more comfort
if
there was a solid plan on the table
local authority leaders are saying that
they haven't been consulted yet um they
are there ready to put the support in
housing providers need to be uh involved
in this exactly what exactly are you
what
exactly are you asking for because you
want a concrete plan on the ground it
feels like there is a concrete plan now
well i'm not sure sorry about that
because
what i saw in the summer was you need
language experts you need experts with
traumatized families you need experts
who can help them contact their
relatives back in the country they've
just fled from you need people who can
sort out schooling very quickly you need
a local authorities completely engaged
in it and you need housing providers
that can all be done and it was done in
the summer i would just like the
reassurance of knowing that plan is in
place not against um you know where
families can
housing a refugee of course i'm not
against that
but i do think the basic support needs
to be put in and i want to hear from
michael gove that those plans are fully
ready and i'm hearing on the ground that
that just isn't the case across the
country so what is labour's um proposal
for refugees then you're talking about
involving local authorities and
involving you know local housing
providers would you like to see an
uncapped number of refugees coming from
ukraine without visas to be housed here
what i want to see is very simple it's a
simple safe route to sanctuary for those
that are fleeing for their lives no one
would disagree with that statement no
well they that's it nobody would
disagree that's not a concrete plan like
you want in the government nobody would
disagree with that but we haven't seen
that in recent weeks but what the
government has put in place is called
embarrassment to our country what's the
concrete plan that you would like to see
then we want emergency protection visas
very simple very straightforward that
could be dealt with on route on advice
centers on route to the united kingdom
so that by the time people are here they
can come straight in the country get the
support that they need very simple very
straightforward should have been thought
through weeks and months ago
the likelihood of an invasion of ukraine
was known weeks ago the home office has
been far too slow far too mean in
relation to this and and frankly the
last few weeks have been an
embarrassment for the united kingdom in
the way that it's dealt with refugees
would you like to see an uncapped number
of these emergency visas well sorry i'm
not going to pluck a number out the air
in the middle of this conflict we can
all see what's happening no i'm not
a number i understand and but i'm just
saying would you like to see a cap on
the number or would it be uncapped i
think look we need to work with our
allies across europe in a coordinated
way and the uk has to play its part i
heard michael gove say tens of thousands
i think plucking a number is wrong we
don't know where this conflict is going
to go we all hope that it de-escalates
but we don't know that and therefore
anybody today putting a number on it i
don't think it's being real i'm not
asking for a number i'm asking if it
should be capped or not that's quite
different well no i don't think it
should be a cap is a number
no cap then
a cap is a number and i'm not going to
i'm not asking you i'm not asking you
whether what the number should be but
i'm asking if if there should be a cap
or it should be uncapped we should
provide sanctuary to all of those that
are fling for their lives um that uh
want to come to the united kingdom and
play our full part it shouldn't be
capped it shouldn't be captured okay
thank you uh right i'm we've obviously
seen more
it almost feels relentless doesn't it
the horrors that we've seen
coming out of ukraine um the uk says
that they're supplying defensive weapons
but ukrainians want to see more military
weapons fighter jets and so on they've
obviously asked for a no-fly zone
do you think the uk needs to be doing
more at this point
we
the labour party in the opposition have
been supportive of the government on the
in-principle stand
standing up to russian aggression and
standing up for the ukrainian people
what
putin wants more than anything is
division he wants nato to be divided he
wants our allies to be divided and he
wants us back here in the united kingdom
be to be divided politically we won't
let that happen
um because i think
um on an issue as important as this we
have to stand together so where the
government has provided military
equipment into ukraine we have supported
that where we've said the government
needs to go further and faster is in
relation to sanctions
those sanctions frankly should have been
in place before this evasion started um
there was a russia report of two years
ago that set out
all the problems and why we needed
sanctions the economic crime bill was
talked about a year ago it's only now
coming on the statute book so i want the
government to go further and fast on
sanctions we will vote for those
measures by the way but i do want the
government to go further on humanitarian
aid refugees i think the home office so
far has got it completely wrong i think
everybody knows they've got it
completely wrong and we need to see
change so we are supportive in principle
on the things that really matter we want
to push the government further and
faster where they're simply not going
fast enough i was trying to get a sense
from michael gove about any red lines
whether the uk response would change
particularly on the use of chemical
weapons it feels like that is a very
real fear for people
if putin uses
chemical weapons a clearly a war crime
is that a point when the military
response from the uk nato potentially
but the uk needs to escalate
there is always the
chilling risk of escalation that none of
us want to see
i think in the middle of a conflict like
this we shouldn't be speculating in the
what ifs
we have to work we have to work in
lockstep
with our nato allies
responding as
things develop but at this stage
discussing what if i don't think is
helpful in a in a conflict like that
even if it could act as a deterrent
potentially there right well at the
moment we have to be absolutely clear
providing uh military equipment the
strongest possible sanctions and i'm
talking about sanctions that don't just
um you know isolate russia but
um [ __ ] russia's ability to function
that's why i want the government to go
further and faster but i think that
sitting in tv studios speculating
if putin does this
then
we we will do that i don't think that's
the role at the moment that has to be
something that's agreed in lockstep with
our nato allies
there are huge implications
of any escalation and
i think we should respond as this
develops what i want to see is obviously
a ceasefire
and the um withdrawal of uh russian
troops from ukraine you know uh that is
what we all want to see and that's what
the measures we're taking are designed
to achieve do you think there's any hope
obviously aspire i mean there's
obviously talks going on are you
optimistic that there could be
some kind of negotiated deal coming up
i'm not optimistic because it's very
difficult to see what the basis of any
agreement could be
but of course if it is possible to
achieve a ceasefire and a withdrawal by
russia then of course like everybody
else i would want that to happen
the shocking images i didn't think in my
lifetime
i would ever see again russian
tanks rolling into a european country
soldiers kissing their children goodbye
as they stay to defend their cities and
their country
and families
fleeing for their life the awful bombing
of a maternity hospital of course if
it's possible to find a way through this
then we should all be uh hoping for that
but am i optimistic no i'm afraid not at
the moment yeah it's it's absolutely
heartbreaking as you say
with your lawyer's hat on it is vladimir
putin a war criminal yes yes what i've
seen already amounts to war crimes
particularly uh the awful attacks on
civilians
and i think it's very important that
he's held to account and is responsible
and all those that are acting with him
know that they too will be held to
account and this is something which we
need to make clear now
um so that those who are involved at the
moment know what the consequences are
there's a gap that we've got to plug and
that is in relation to the aggression of
the invasion that is not something that
at the moment can be dealt with by
international tribunals which is why i
and others have suggested that we set up
a tribunal
to deal with this bit like the nuremberg
tribunal so that the act of aggression
itself the aggressive invasion that's
going on is itself something for which
putin and everybody who is acting with
him can be held to account for um i want
to talk to you about lord lebadeer the
newspaper proprietor son of a former kgb
uh agent um we spoke to michael goverly
he said no one had raised any security
concerns with him about him over the
years and that we shouldn't fall into
the trap of effectively demonizing
people from russia what's your response
to that
well of course we shouldn't just
demonize people from russia i completely
agree with that but that isn't the leber
dev case
the
media today are saying there were
further reservations by the security and
intelligence services which were known
before this appointment was made
and we know that concerns were raised
apparently with the prime minister now
in light of the revelations today or the
further revelations today i think the
prime minister's got serious questions
to answer what did he know
um and did he override security advice
um i've already suggested that
um there needs to be a process here to
look into this appointment
the intelligence and security committee
could look into it obviously that's a
matter for them but there needs to be a
process but i think the lord's
appointments commission as well i've
written to them to say
in the exceptional circumstances of this
case where there were security issues in
relation to an appointment by the prime
minister to the house of lords will they
release the advice or the information
they were giving and will they review
the appointment because
um the more
that the media probe into this the more
serious the reservations it appears of
the security and intelligence services
and the more the judgment of the prime
minister is called into question the
judgment the prime minister called into
question what exactly are you saying
that he did wrong here well that's why i
want to process because i haven't seen
the materials
almost certainly confidential by their
nature but i don't think we can sit back
when there were
revelations that we've seen in our
papers today about the security concerns
in relation to lebedev and say oh well
the appointment's been made it doesn't
really matter this is a question of
national security let us have a process
to look into what actually happened what
did the prime minister know
and what did he do in response to that
and i think that's the least that we're
entitled to in relation to this
appointment
um i want to talk a little bit about
what's happening here in the uk because
things are going to get let's be frank
really difficult for people and you'll
have noticed it if you've filled your
car up recently uh with energy bills
increasing there's going to be an awful
lot of people faced with that terrible
choice between effectively heating their
homes and eating yeah what's the big
idea from the leader of the opposition
to try and ameliorate the biggest cost
of living crisis that we could have seen
for decades well the first thing is this
is not
um
only caused by the invasion of ukraine
this predates we were in a costa living
crisis before russia invaded ukraine so
this has been something that's been on
the cards for a very long time so what's
the um what we've said is do something
now to deal with the energy bills that
people are facing as everybody knows
most people are going to face an energy
bill rise of about 700 pounds in just a
few weeks time
and now with what's happened
internationally there's likely to be
another thousand pounds or so in the
autumn so we the labour party have said
take action what we would do
is have a windfall tax on the oil and
gas companies in the north sea who have
made more profit than they expected
because of the global price and you just
trust them to pass it on them to the
consumers more in their own words more
money than they know what to do with use
that to reduce the
energy bills for households by up to 600
pounds for those particularly in need so
a very direct act that we would do
the government says no no no no we don't
want to ask any more of the oil and gas
companies we will ask working families
and families to do it instead we'll give
them a loan is there another worry
though we'll give them a loan of 200
which they will then pay back over the
next few years so the political divide
here is huge we say oil and gas
companies have to pay their part
particularly when they've had profits
they didn't expect the government says
we're going to hammer working families
but at the same time at the same time is
there not a concern firstly that this
windfall tax will not necessarily be
passed on to consumers but also that it
could almost act as a distance
respectively
to invest more in oil out of the north
sea at a time when we are facing big
questions about our energy security in
the uk these are windfall taxes these
are taxes on profits that those
companies did not expect to make the
global price has been higher than they
had anticipated therefore they've made
more profit than they anticipated they
have said they've used expressions such
as we've got more money than we know
what to do with the argument the
government has well we won't touch that
instead we'll ask families okay to foot
the bill by having a loan that they
don't want and paying it off is a it
just shows the complete difference in
priorities of the labour party that
wants to look after families who've got
energy bills they can't afford and the
government that's putting even more
pressure on those families boris johnson
reportedly going to saudi arabia next
year to talk about and getting oil
potentially more or potentially from
there there's obviously big human rights
concerns about saudi arabia are you
comfortable with us relying more on
saudi arabia for our energy if we're
trying to stop the use of russian oil if
i were the prime minister i would have a
uh
an energy strategy
here in the uk
i just want to get a clear answer well
there are human rights of course the
human rights issues
the direct question is should we be
accepting uh more oil from saudi arabia
we need an energy security strategy for
the uk i thought i'm really not clear
but i just really just answered me out
and then i we need an energy strategy
for the uk that's been lacking for 10
years what i would like to see is an
energy strategy that's based on the uk
not so reliant on other countries saudi
arabia or other countries one of the
things we've learned in the last few
years and particularly in the last few
weeks and months of over reliance on
international imports is energy now
aren't we should we be looking to get
more energy from saudi arabia right now
what is it if there's anything not if
there's anything could be done to bring
the price down now then
so
well well you say okay the problem with
energy strategies we've always done the
short term over the last 12 years and we
are where we are we need to have a
strategy that you know
fast forwards on nuclear doubles our
wind capability onshore increases it
offshore develops hydrogen and actually
has a plan to insulate our homes to
bring the whole price of energy i want
an energy
strategy which is secure and makes us
less reliant on what happens abroad and
therefore if this is a short-term
measure to bring down prices well that's
one thing if it is a long-term strategy
to make us dependent on saudi arabia
instead of russia then i would take a
fundamentally different approach okay
that makes sense um now talking about
sanctions which you have done before
chelsea football club obviously been hit
by these crippling sanctions because of
their owner roman ibranovich they're not
even allowed to sell tickets today they
are playing newcastle united and who
obviously have been
owned by a group led by saudi arabia's
sovereign wealth fund you're a football
fan yourself do you think this should be
a watershed moment for football to look
at how it's funded yes i think that
moment has passed we've had a review
tracy crouch a conservative mp who's
respected across the house has carried
out that review um and i think the
government now needs to act on it so yes
this is in very sharp focus now but
actually the need to look again at
governance in football has been there
for a very long time now okay a very
quick question i just thought you might
better clear up and there's something
some people were slightly confused about
whether you're still calling for the
prime minister to resign at the minute
or because of ukraine you've withdrawn
that call
what is the position on that do you
think boris johnson should resign
i haven't changed my mind on boris
johnson i think he's lost the moral
authority to lead i don't think he's fit
to be our prime minister
um i can't force him to resign only tory
mps can do that
but i have to say that just at the
moment my total focus is on the ukraine
and what we have to do in response to
the russian aggression there and i think
everybody would understand why my focus
is on that vital issue just at the
moment yeah of course uh kias dharma
labour leader thank you very much for uh
coming on the program today's much
appreciated thank you
now the ukrainian president uh zelensky
says that his country is working with
the european commission to try and
fast-track ukraine's application for
membership of the eu the ukrainian
member of parliament lessio vasilenko is
part of a delegation to the european
parliament and is currently in
strasbourg for us thank you very much
for being on the program today can you
just explain what you are doing in
strasbourg
essentially uh nine ukrainian members of
parliament all women are part of the
international task force to ram up
support ukraine both from eu countries
and council of europe countries so last
week it was the session of the european
parliament and we were working uh the
delegations of the eu parliamentarians
to see how we can
move more on more sanctions more robust
sanctions against russia especially with
certain countries who
took half measures
and also how we can do more to expedite
ukraine's membership in the eu this week
is going to be about the council of
europe expelling russia from every
single body of the council of europe the
committee of ministers last week failed
to make such a decision so it's now up
to the parliamentary assembly of the
council of europe tuesday and monday
will be the decisive days and we hope
that the resolution with the final
resolution will read that russia will
not just be invited to leave or of its
own accord and hence be uh
able to come back whenever it sees fit
but that the resolution will read that
russia is actually expelled and then it
will be up to the council of europe
countries to uh make the decision of
when uh they are happy to welcome russia
back and invite him back
you mentioned there that some countries
have only taken half measures on
sanctions who are you talking about
well it's the obvious ones uh germany
france uh
the the the major countries they're not
doing uh
nearly as as much as they could be doing
uh the same goes it goes for the
purchase of russian oil and gas okay
germany made the decision yesterday to
stop with the purchases of oil and coal
but gas still remains a big one every
penny that goes into the russian economy
goes to finance the russian army which
essentially is committing a genocide of
the ukrainian people by massacring
civilians every single day every single
day i wake up to the news that more and
more civilians were killed there are
more civilian losses in ukraine than
military losses that says something
about the type of warfare they are
waging it's a terrorist state waging a
terrorist war against an independent
nation and they must be stopped with all
means and money and economic sanctions
are uh very strongly towards them um
it's absolutely horrific what you say
and i just want to talk a bit about the
position you find yourself in and we
might better show a picture of you i
believe
um you've uh taken up
a gun yourself and you say that you're
prepared
to use it
you've got three children including a
nine month old
just just talk me through you're in
strasbourg at the moment are you
planning on returning to ukraine your
children in ukraine what's your own
situation
uh so my my own situation is complicated
you know how you you put the
on your social media profile it's
complicated this is my situation right
now uh
i'm uh very blessed to be in a much
better position than many people living
in besieged towns such as volnavaja
which has been destroyed yesterday since
yesterday it's a town in ukraine which
had one hundred and thousand one hundred
thousand people and now it's no longer
considered livable it's no longer a town
uh
yesterday it was the last day that city
was existing as a city so i guess i'm
lucky that that at least i'm living
breathing i'm in safety i'm in a country
right now where there is no war where
missiles are not flying my kids are in
safety uh i in fact have a couple of
hours with
them just now just as we speak so i'm
extremely blessed that i have the
opportunity to at least see them for for
at least a while but uh once this
diplomatic mission to strasbourg is over
that's it i go back i go back to ukraine
that's that's a set uh
said given but uh where do i go back to
ukraine i don't know because uh
my um
my trip to to uh
to this
to strasbourg and later on it will also
include the uk
uh so on
next week i will also be in the uk also
trying to speak to government officials
and parliamentary parliamentarians uh
regarding uh regarding more sanctions
and regarding more support for ukraine
but really after that on dating so much
i go back to ukraine the question is
where where is that going to be uh
because every time uh i look at the news
more and more cities are getting bombed
as well in western ukraine so it's very
very indefinite i hope to be able to go
back to kiev to
to my own apartment at some point um i
mean i as a normal person i miss it
greatly and
i would love to just be home and have
somewhere to call home
yeah i can completely understand that
and thank you for you know
sharing the experience that you're
feeling like so many people in ukraine i
just want to be able to go home and you
mentioned there that you are hoping to
speak to the uk parliament and see if
there's more that they can do
um spoke to michael gove and also the
labour leader kier stammer on the show
today asking if there were any points at
which the uk should escalate its
response to things like providing more
weapons or providing a no-fly zone it
felt that they were quite reluctant to
commit to anything like that what do you
make of the uk government's position
well today ukraine relies most on the uk
and on the us to be honest these are the
two strategic partners that have always
been around through all of the eight
years of war that russia has been
waiting against ukraine uh today the uk
has uh
well not only the opportunity but also
in
my view the responsibility to become the
leader of the anti-putin coalition which
is forming in eastern europe uh
yesterday uh in the speeches we heard
from uh
from uh russian tv presenters which are
essentially the rupers the the
microphones of the kremlin uh the
message was very very clear that after
ukraine russia is not about to stop and
that they are going to continue their
invasion across the eastern uh block of
countries to to get back that big
russian empire they all dream about
essentially that is a declaration of
of war on uh european states and on nato
member states before it's too late i
feel that the santi putin coalition
formed of uh baltic states of poland of
uh georgia possibly although georgia has
been very very quiet these days
surprisingly um
of the uk again of the nordic states
this anti-putin coalition could really
be uh the the thing and the mechanism
the vehicle that can stop putin uh
before it gets too late and before the
extent of the damage and the extent of
losses of people's lives grows more than
that of the world war two
um it's it's as you say the the loss of
life is so devastating what are people
telling you um from ukraine you must be
speaking to people and friends family
members who are still there
every single day uh i to be honest i i
feel guilty for even getting like the
the four or five hours of sleep uh that
i've been getting through these uh uh a
little bit more than two weeks through
these 18 days
uh because every time every hour
something is happening uh there's either
missiles or shellings or evacuation
buses being shot
tonight
really the attacks have extended uh to
to the west of ukraine actually that
happened already since last night
as well
so now they bombed this uh peace and
security center that was located uh just
outside of leave just 28 kilometers away
from poland people in poland were
sending messages saying that they heard
tremors in their homes as everything in
the night shook
so this is how far they are pushing now
they're really the russians are really
pushing on the borders and i think it's
gonna be uh very little time before they
start attacking poland
that's really concerning and perspective
and thank you so much for taking the
time to
talk to us this morning we appreciate it
thank you thank you thank you
very powerful interview there from
lazier fascilenco we are due to speak
live to the deputy prime minister of
ukraine ola stephanie but she has been
called to an emergency meeting in
ukraine as you can imagine it's a very
fluid situation there if she is able to
join us we'll bring you that interview
when we can
and i have something else to talk to you
about this morning because we are
launching an exciting new program later
in the spring it's called the take with
sophie ridge and the idea is it's going
to be live every wednesday evening at 9
00 p.m we're going to try and take the
political temperature midweek and react
to the big stories of the day perhaps
prime minister's questions for example
and we'll be of course talking to
government ministers and opposition
parties along with other interesting
mps as well
but as always we're keen to talk to
you as well this is the most important
thing of all we want to get your
reaction to the politics so we're
searching for a regular panel of sky
news viewers to take part in the program
and to give their opinions on the big
political issues of the week so if you
want to get involved if you want to talk
to me every wednesday then please email
the take with safety ridge at sky dot uk
that's the take with sophie ridge at sky
dot uk
put a couple of lines about yourself
there what your politics are there's
more information online if you want to
find out more that's news.sky.com
plus our weekly polycast is back this
sunday so if you scan the qr code on
your screen right now then you will find
the saferidge on sunday podcast and you
can subscribe so it's in your feed every
week so on the podcast there'll be
highlights of the interviews from the
show a bit of post-match analysis and
also an
insight i guess into how we put the
program together
each week from me and the team so you
can find it and subscribe wherever you
usually get your podcast just search for
sophie bridge on sunday it should be
available again later today
now vladimir putin has responded to
opposition to the war in his own country
with increasing repression new laws
threatened 15 years in jail for sharing
so-called misinformation thousands of
people have been detained for protesting
now alexa navalny is the kremlin's most
prominent critic he's on jail
and now his spokesperson has also been
placed on a most wanted list as well now
to get a sense of just how harsh the
crackdown is in russia and and you hope
there may be of an uprising against
putin i spoke to alexander valni's chief
of staff leonard volkov who is in
lithuania this is what he had to tell me
thank you so much for coming on the
program today
we've all seen the horrors coming out of
ukraine children killed as they've been
trying to flee maternity hospitals
being bombed
how have you felt watching that
it feels enormously painful it feels
i mean
i want to cry
like putin is president of russia this
is putin's war this is not my war i'm
trying to cry as loud as possible and i
asked my fellow competitors to cry this
is not our war not in our name he's
doing it not in our name but
it looks like so far we are not
strong enough to stop him and he's
continuing to do all these enormous
things and crimes and war crimes in our
name and we can't stop thinking about
how it will define
future of our country
in the 21st century what will people
think and
tell of us like in 10 or 20 years will
russia become
the the nazi germany of the 21st century
that's actually the questions that could
impose us and we urge all our
compatriots like to do whatever possible
to stop him before it's too late you
talk about the russian people perhaps
not being strong enough to stop
what's happening and of course there
have been russians who have been
protesting against the war in ukraine
but some in the west might think why
haven't more people being taken to the
streets to try and overflow vladimir
putin what would you say to that
when when i hear this question i say oh
sorry guys you and the west still don't
understand a thing
uh this is this is big problem like the
the west was trying to to comprehend
like putin putin's russian and what's
going on and still many people do not
understand what that what's actually
going on so in russia now
just turning it out for a peaceful
protest rally against war you would face
up to 15 years imprisonment and still
there are people that participate in
this protest like every day and every
weekend and we've seen massive protest
on sunday march 6 and we have called for
another rallies and we will see in other
realities this sunday
this despite enormous risks these people
are taking and
last sunday
over 5 000 people have been detained
which means that over like 50 000 people
at least
have turned out this despite this
enormous harassment and risk and uh
persecution they are facing like 50 000
people brave enough to say okay i cannot
accept all this horror being done like
in my name so i'm i'm ready to go to
jail for 15 years just just because this
is so unbearable
everyone who protests now in russia is
enormously brave and everyone who who
protests represents
thousands other people who stay at home
who are not brave enough to turn out but
they are not to be blamed putin has
built an authoritarian regime for 20
years a regime where like public
expression of descent has been made
barely possible i think you're right
when you say that people in the west
perhaps just don't understand the
situation and i think there has been
perhaps a misunderstanding of who putin
is it can be quite difficult for us to
really predict what he's going to do
because he is such a different leader to
the ones we're used to
if the war isn't going as planned as
many think how do you think he's going
to react to someone who's seen putin
operate over many years
well first of all here i have to admit
we also didn't get putin right so we the
russian position we have been fighting
with him for years we have considered
him to be evil like poisoned our friends
with novichok and arresting us in harass
so i've spent like
four months under arrest and many
many of my friends much more and so on
but we always have considered him racial
evil vibrational
now with this war it's clear it's clear
that we were wrong because these were
first of all things doesn't make any
sense
he already destroyed russian economy he
already destroyed russian army he
already destroyed russian future like
there is i mean the the future of our
country is now like very very unclear
what it will be like the deparia in the
world like for many years now
so no rational man would do it and we
have considered him to be rational so
now we have to reassess it and we have
to consider him to be like a crazy
person which apparently he is now
it's so come it's so challenging to to
predict what a crazy person would do
next we try more to address like people
around him who
cannot be crazy like all of them and of
course our letter actions
the protest and uh
working on sanctions list and talking to
like western leaders on this
functionalist are all to install as many
cracks as possible in in the in putin's
inner circle people around him like a
police coup a like a revolution someone
of his close co-workers turning against
him it's pretty much the only chance now
to stop this
war
uh what would putin do if
not everything goes according to his
plan well everything already doesn't go
up according to his plan he was clearly
playing a blitzkrieg he was about to
take
keith in maybe four or five days
when he is now calling for uh people to
come from syria to join russian armed
forces it's a very clear sign that not
everything went according to his plan of
course no initial plan could include
importing like syrians uh syrian
warriors like to protect the the russian
christian of world so but now a lot of
things of course depend uh depending on
the people of ukraine of how they are
ready to fight and they're doing it very
good on people of russia how they're
ready to fight and we are calling for
protests and people turn and participate
in this protest and of course of the
world like it's now very clear that
enormous cost has to be paid to stop
this for
this all the sanctions of course they
also
uh
create a burden on the european economy
that that's quite clear but this cost
has to be paid because otherwise putin
will just
destroy the world you say he could
destroy the world do you think he would
be prepared to
use nuclear weapons that's clearly what
many leaders around the world are
concerned about
as he is crazy enough
we cannot we can expect unfortunately
everything
uh he's clearly not winning the war
against ukraine and he might think about
other solutions more powerful weapons
more powerful
solutions to to change the course of
this war which is now not so successful
for him
and just finally um in your answer
earlier you said that the one chance of
ending this would be for those around
putin to try and stop him
do you think that could happen the
kremlin do you think if there do you
think there are enough cracks in those
around him in his inner circle to stop
this war and to perhaps even depose him
yeah i think so i think i mean this is
probably the the only chance but it is
quite feasible
because
his elite is clearly unhappy with what
is going on and many oligarchs have
already publicly spoken out against
putin's war
which is quite unheard of and many of
people around him are of course also not
like bloody
maniacs and do not want
this all to happen
so i believe that rationally
it could happen that
some some of people in his inner circle
will decide that okay they are ready to
take the risk but to stop it and they
will know that well the world will be
thankful also for them uh i can't call
any names i can't say this guy will will
probably try to
create uh such a revolutionary situation
this is not predictable but
we have to keep trying keep working to
create more pressure on these people
around footing to make this scenario
more probable and thank you so much for
your insights it's been really
fascinating to talk so thank you
leonard volkov there on his perspective
as one of the uh outspoken critics of
vladimir putin now we are still hoping
to bring you uh olha stefaninska who is
the deputy uh prime minister of ukraine
we'll keep you posted
on how that is going obviously a very
fluid situation there
in a moment after this break we'll also
be running through today's interviews
and have a look at some of the analysis
of that with our deputy political editor
sam coats so don't go anywhere
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello welcome to sophie ridge on sunday
the take where we take a moment to look
back at this morning's big interviews
and discuss what it all means with our
deputy political editor
sam
coates of course my first show back for
nine months there is no way i thought we
would be in this situation i mean it's
just it's such a difficult watch i'm
sure you feel
exactly the same just how
relentless and helpless you feel when
you watch what is
unfolding in ukraine and the government
in the uk trying of course to
do something
michael gove unveiling the plan for
refugees i was really trying to get into
the nitty-gritty about whether or not
it's going to work how many people we're
talking about safe getting concerns how
quickly it's going to go can we rely on
the home office to actually make this
happen and we'll be listening to his
interview a little bit later as well uh
plus uh sir kiyostama the leader of the
labour party at giving the opposition
perspective but to be completely honest
the interview that
i really remember from today was that of
the ukrainian mep a picture of her
holding a gun
talking about her three children one
nine month old talking about how she
feels guilty if she sleeps for four or
five hours at night because that's more
than her friends and family back in
ukraine
are getting and i guess those are the
voices that really bring
it home uh just the situation that we
are in
at the minute um let's bring in sam
coats now shall we our deputy political
editor listening to the show uh today
sam good to talk to you what were your
main takeaways
hello sophie it's great to have you back
and what a world that we've
that you step back into i mean one theme
ran through all of the interviews that
you did and that is the
massive uncertainty that the world that
british politicians that ukrainians all
face
right now and as we went through the
various guests you heard the plans for
refugees the plans potential plans to
deal with crippling energy costs with
rising prices but the bottom line sophie
is that nobody knows whether we are
going to be dealing with this ukrainian
crisis the incursion invasion by russia
in three months in six months or in 10
years and the answer to all of the
questions that you posed to leading
political figures are different
depending on what that is we just cannot
know and at one end of the spectrum we
were talking you were talking to your
guests about nuclear war and the
realistic prospect that that could be
something that we have to face up to
chilling uh after two decades three
decades where that hasn't at all been on
the agenda but at the other end of the
spectrum impossible questions about what
to do if there are shortages on so many
fronts energy food fertilizer which is
going to just make everyday life a
misery for millions of britons so it is
a perilous time and i feel that having
gone through brexit and having gone
through covert we have talked about the
difficult times ahead uh that those
potentially could have mean but we are
now talking about stuff on a new scale
and it was
that conversation that you began uh with
by talking to michael gove the leveling
up secretary about a government that is
now realistically having to ask
questions about nuclear warfare chemical
warfare and the escalation what types of
escalation and response there would have
to be to that that just showed that we
are in a new universe when it comes to
the current political situation yeah i
think that's right sam and actually to
be honest i was quite shocked by
what we ended up talking about on the
show today
you know you feel a responsibility date
you that you don't want to be alarmist
but at the same time you also don't want
to not address things that world leaders
are clearly thinking about all the time
when it comes to their response to
russia and i think we can perhaps bring
in a little bit of what michael gove
said earlier he was talking about the in
his words grisly options that president
putin could decide to adopt
we know that vladimir putin uh is
prepared to escalate there are several
grizzly options that he has
at his disposal we know that um from
what vladimir putin has done elsewhere
from what he's uh done in syria and what
he has done in chechnya that he is
capable of devastation on a terrible
terrible scale russia is a nuclear-armed
power um its military doctrine um uh it
clearly has a
uh
a set of steps by which they can move to
that we're in perilous uh territory
perilous territory and sam i mean
he obviously doesn't want to be drawn
into too many specifics but it's pretty
clear what he's saying isn't it
absolutely you asked him about chemical
weapons and he made clear that in the
event that
president putin decides to use chemical
weapons as happened in syria not that
many years ago
there will be
another concerted escalation from the
west from nato countries
from all those that are opposing
president putin although i think it's
legitimate to ask
sophie just how much there is left in
the locker that we can do to russia what
is the next gear that you can go up to
given that trading ties energy links all
of those things are being severed with
uh russia and what feels like a daily
basis at the moment what else could we
do that isn't already in train and then
that conversation that nobody wants to
hear which is the fact that russia has
hundreds of nuclear weapons could uh
some of those dark hints out of the
kremlin actually uh materialize now uh
let's all i think everybody hopes that
that's not where uh we go but somewhere
inside government there is starting to
have to be some planning to have uh to
uh to discuss those questions what um uh
what could the various steps that russia
are taking look like uh and i think that
uh there is a lot of talk uh you were
talking to
alexander navalny's chief of staff and
he was making absolutely clear that he
does think that president putin is of a
frame of mind where he could use nuclear
weapons and i think that uh
this is one of the reasons why
for all of the bullish response of the
west uh you nevertheless had joe biden
over the weekend coming out and saying
uh that there are limits to what they
will do what the west will do to defend
ukraine and that limit
does include not sending troops uh to
ukraine itself for the very fear that
this could escalate into some kind of
nuclear conflict which nobody wants to
see
the thing that really struck me from the
interviews today was
how people are struggling to really
second-guess the frame of mind that
putin is in as you were referring to
that michael gove talked about his
ruthlessness leonard volkov at the chief
of staff of alexander valley saying that
they thought he was at least rational
before now they have to concentrate that
he's effectively someone who is crazy
and
as a result very very unpredictable
let's just bring in shall we uh leonard
volkov because i thought this was
actually quite a revealing interview
let's listen to what he had to say about
what putin could do
do you think he would be prepared to
use nuclear weapons that's clearly what
many leaders around the world are
concerned about
as he is crazy enough
we cannot we can expect unfortunately
everything uh he's clearly not winning
the war against ukraine and he might
think about
other solutions more powerful weapons
more powerful
solutions to
to change the course of this world
the other a big topic of discussion of
course this morning and on the program
as well was refugees at the un
estimating that 2.6 million people have
already fled at ukraine that number of
course could rise many of them the most
vulnerable uh women children the elderly
of course many of this working age men
have stayed back to fight
and there is pressure on the government
to do more in the uk as well michael
gove was on the program today
revealing details of a new scheme where
people will be paid 350 pounds a month
if they house one of the refugees
fleeing from conflict this is what
michael gove had to say about how that
would
work what's your estimate for the number
of people who could come to the uk
through this scheme um tens of thousands
once we do everything we can in order to
provide that humanitarian support
expertise uh boots on the ground money
alongside that we can then see how many
people we can take to the uk and again
many of the people who are there um will
want to at the moment stay
close to ukraine so there'll be money
available for local authorities money
available for much um for each uh
individual who comes will be just over
ten thousand pounds per individual
people can register their interest on um
monday uh matching will be taking place
from friday um i would expect that in a
week's time we'll see the first people
coming here under the scheme
let's bring sam straight back in shall
we and there has been criticism of the
uk government for being sluggish
effectively in bringing refugees over to
the uk not having uh visas wave like so
many other countries in the eu do you
think this scheme will be enough to
silence that criticism
well i thought there were two features
of the big scheme that michael gave is
going to formally announce in the house
of the houses of parliament tomorrow uh
that struck me
um and it does as you say come after
days of criticism that the government
isn't being generous enough they haven't
just opened the doors to ukrainians uh
there are conditions that hurdles that
ukrainians have to get over
and checks that they have to uh pass in
order to come to the uk
um the first big thing
that struck me about michael gove on
your show this morning was that he was
making clear that this is only one part
of a much bigger armory to help uh
individual ukrainians almost the last
option uh of a long list that also
included humanitarian aid uh money
uh and practical support for people so
they could uh preferably it would seem
to be uh he is saying stay near a
ukraine rather than actually coming to
the united kingdom so the british
government's position is that they don't
expect many people to want to come to
the uk and that's why the scheme is only
likely to bring in a much more limited
number of people than you are seeing
being re-housed in companies in
countries like poland uh where hundreds
of thousands of people
are pouring across
the border so they are justifying uh
proudly uh the more limited nature of
the scheme that they are uh constructing
then the second thing and again i
thought that this came out well uh in
the interview just now uh is that some
of those um hurdles that ukrainians are
gonna have to uh clear are quite tricky
effectively ukrainians wanting to come
to the united kingdom are going to have
to be matched uh with either an
individual here or a company or a
charity they've got to have to what is
going to be known as a sponsor but it's
not totally clear yet and we'll get more
details tomorrow about how that
sponsorship scheme will work i mean it's
effectively like a sort of
this is a crude and perhaps
inappropriate way it's sort of like a
dating app to match the two sides how do
you spot
who you want to help from ukraine if
you're a british citizen wanting to help
uh to perhaps give them your spare room
does this mean that people who are more
vulnerable are less likely to get a
match because they could be considered
unappealing i think that this is an
innovative scheme and i think the
government will get credit for drawing
something up at pace but there are
potential problems with it as we
as we move through the months because
effectively individuals look like
they'll in the uk look like they'll be
taking responsibility and playing a role
in choosing who comes into their house
which will work in some cases
but
it could prove a bit tricky as time goes
on particularly if there are people on
the uk side who don't have the best of
motives uh that people are desperate to
be matched on the ukrainian side so
don't perhaps present themselves as they
as they should i think there are there
are particularly a lot of questions for
this scheme that we will hear about uh
in the comments tomorrow yeah certainly
right um sam thank you very much for
your analysis uh so far and we're gonna
have more from sam and me and analyzing
those interviews including uh with the
labour leader sakir stama after this
break
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist metal
are you trying to run me over sir philip
no go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who've made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of america's opioid
crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
christchurch has been changed forever by
what happened
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back to sophie ridge on
sunday the take where we take you back
through the morning's interviews with
some analysis from me and our deputy
political editor
sam coats well one of the big stories of
the morning of course has been the uk
government's new scheme to try and house
refugees from ukraine we spoke to
michael goff about it we also spoke to
the labour leader kierstarma to try and
find out what he thought of the new
housing scheme
i'm not against the scheme that he is
proposing um i have to say the more you
questioned him the more i queried
exactly how it's going to work um but
actually i'd have more comfort
if
there was a solid plan on the table you
need
language experts you need experts with
traumatized families you need experts
who can help them contact their
relatives back in the country they've
just fled from you need people who can
sort out schooling very quickly you need
a local authorities are completely
engaged in it and you need housing
providers that can all be done and it
was done in the summer i would just like
the reassurance of knowing that plan is
in place
well let's bring in our deputy political
editor uh sam coates shall we it's
always quite a difficult position for an
opposition leader isn't it and when
you're in
a time of international crisis to get
the tone right
on criticizing the government if you
needed but doing it constructively what
did you make of sakirshama's interview
this morning
oh gosh yes sophie i
we were sort of
walking along a bit of a wobbly
tightrope at times i thought because
kirstjamer doesn't oppose the new
refugee scheme that the government will
announce tomorrow but has lots of
criticisms uh about it a lot of those
criticisms felt to me like criticisms of
the way that the old afghan refugee
scheme set up in the summer to deal with
that crisis
a lot of those criticisms that were
relevant back then uh what i thought was
interesting that kirsten didn't really
do is basically challenge the
fundamentals that it's based around the
system of sponsorship that we were
talking about before the break it was
like he had some boilerplate criticisms
of refugee schemes and rolled them out
for this rather than uh perhaps picking
up some of the ways that the new scheme
may or may not um
ask it is difficult for for kierstarma
because as he made clear he wants to
show that the uk is united against
president putin whilst maintaining the
ability to uh to criticize boris johnson
uh about whom he said frankly his mind
hadn't changed and uh still did not
think uh was fit for office but was not
calling uh to go right now but i
actually thought that the difficult
position that the labour leader was in
came out most clearly in your
questioning about what to do in the
future about energy because it does look
as if britain the us are all going to
have to go to saudi arabia itself which
has faced massive criticism not just for
the executions yesterday but also uh the
murder of the uh american journalist um
daniel khashoggi uh and serial human
rights abuses over the uh over the years
now michael gove was clearly
uncomfortable about boris johnson going
to saudi arabia to ask them to turn on
the taps if possible of oil so we can
lower the energy price kierstarma well
he was
he on the one hand on the other hand did
it a bit he on the one hand said he
wanted a long-term energy strategy uh
that didn't involve saudi america in the
mix but then at the end of your
interview essentially conceded if in the
short term to bring down prices he did
barcelona needs to go to saudi arabia
that is one thing he just doesn't want
to see it in the longer term
and i think that kind of
that kind of answer does risk
potentially dismaying some labor
activists who perhaps
might want more clarity on what
essentially could be seen as a human
rights issue um with kirsten not sort of
coming down in the middle ground between
these two very complex uh complex issues
but the challenge for kierstarma as
always is to try and provide clarity and
cut through uh and too many of those
answers where you're seeking the middle
ground does risk the danger that you
don't yeah i think that's the key isn't
it with cut through kirsten is obviously
one of these people who likes to feel he
is behaving in a reasonable way he can
see both sides perhaps at that kind of
loyally you know seeing both sides of
the argument trait coming through but
that does sometimes mean you don't
necessarily get those headlines that are
really
going to
cut through from that perspective so are
you expecting then tomorrow uh just very
quickly sam before we leave um
sakirstama to be
generally supportive of the government
scheme
well his opening words to you were i
don't oppose the scheme this would be a
position that kirsten was taken to an
awful lot of things that boris johnson
would do as many on the left of his
party do
keep pointing out so yes cautious
limited welcome but then label will go a
long way towards unpicking the detail
perhaps more in the new detail that's
being set out at the sponsorship end of
this rather than on the previous
problems that refugee schemes have seen
in the past
thank you so much uh sam for being with
us this morning good to be talking to
you again on a sunday morning so we
appreciate your time and worth saying
that sam is going to be hopefully with
us on the podcast later too which is
returning
later today the sophie ridge on sunday
uh podcast with lots more analysis from
the interviews of the show as well
it's great to be back and thank you very
much for uh giving up some of your
sunday morning to join me as well it's
much appreciated and that is it from
safe route on sunday this morning we'll
be back of course uh next week 8 30 a.m
on sunday mornings sky news hope you see
them
[Music]
oh
[Music]